I think ultimately service is the path
to self I think humans are built to
serve I think if you're not happy it's
because you're not serving every day we
all want to wake up and feel like what
we do matters to somebody else we want
to feel like the job we're going to or
the business we're creating or whatever
we're going to do today is going to have
an impact on somebody else and some
people you and I and probably most of
your listeners we want to change the
world we want to have a big impact we
want to go and have our message reach
wide and far but not because of us but
because of the impact that we want to
create and other people like my wife
Nina she doesn't want to have a big
mission but she serves the 25 closest
people to us is the glue for our family
remember everybody's birthday and what
they're doing and what they need and
what they're going through and all of
the stuff that I forget and probably I
should get better at everybody wants to
serve serving others is hardwired into
our brain